Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hoy cuando venía para acá
me pregunté muchas veces a qué venía
Mucha ciencia, mucha tecnología,
mucho pensamiento científico
y yo decía ¿qué tengo para hacer acá?
La verdad es que creo en el destino
y siento que algo me puso
en estas tablas hoy.
Nací en Montevideo,
hace unos cuantos años,
y quiero compartir
una historia con Uds.
Cuando tenía 18 años
era una joven muy activa, como quizás
muchos de Uds. que tienen 18 ahora.
Nadaba por la mañana,
entraba temprano a trabajar
trabajaba jornada completa
e iba a estudiar por la noche.
¡Estaba enamorada!
Estaba enamorada de un joven de 19 años
que se llamaba Guillermo,
que era jugador de básquet profesional
y que tenía unos ojos verdes increíbles.
Llegó el verano, planeamos vacaciones
y decidimos irnos a un campamento en
la costa, en la ciudad de Piriápolis
con sus hermanas.
Lo estábamos pasando bárbaro
y uno de los días del campamento
decidimos salir juntos, solos,
a conocer un pueblo cercano,
en la frontera con Brasil.
Fuimos, pasamos un día maravilloso.
Volvimos...
era 7 de enero.
Era un día de mucho sol, con
un cielo celeste y 40 grados.
Viajábamos en una moto
y cuando estábamos a dos kilómetros
del campamento, de regreso,
paramos en el cruce de unas rutas
porque vimos que en una de las rutas
venía un micro de larga distancia.
Ese día se apagó la luz para mí.
Y cuando me encontré de nuevo conmigo,
tuve que tomar una decisión...
elegir cómo vivir esta vida nueva,
esta vida que estaba teniendo
como oportunidad, casi como un regalo.
Y el día que me pusieron
de pie por primera vez,
el médico que colocó la prótesis
que llevo puesta me dijo:
todo lo que viene ahora
está en tus manos,
todo lo que viene de ahora en adelante,
para el resto de tu vida...
Nunca me imaginé que esas palabras,
que recuerdo tan claramente,
iban a tener un símbolo
tan fuerte en lo que pasó después.
Bueno, un buen día me dieron de alta,
volví a mi trabajo
y ahí fue el otro
gran impacto que recibí,
un impacto para el que
no estaba preparada
un impacto que tenía que ver
con la mirada de los otros.
Volver a mi lugar de trabajo
y sentir la mirada de pena,
la lástima con la que
mis compañeros me recibían
una mirada puesta en
mis bastones canadienses
y no en mis 18 años, en mis ganas
de superar o de volver a vivir.
Cambió mi vida y por eso
muchos años después
decidí dedicarme a pensar, a trabajar y
a invitar a otros para trabajar y pensar
sobre el peso social de la discapacidad.
Un peso social que no está puesto en
la situación de discapacidad misma
con la que conviven más de 2 millones de
personas con discapacidad en este país,
sino en el peso social más grosero,
permítanme decirlo así
con el que nos encontramos a diario
que es esa mirada que
devalúa la diferencia.
Un peso social absolutamente contundente.
Y cuando nosotros hablamos de discapacidad
pensamos siempre que el problema
son las escaleras,
el problema es la falta
de accesibilidad al medio físico,
el problema es...
todas las barreras que Uds. pueden
imaginar cuando yo hablo de este tema.
Es verdad, esas barreras son un problema,
sí, en lo cotidiano.
Pero ese no es el problema principal,
el problema principal de las
personas con discapacidad
está en las mentes de Uds.,
está en la cabeza de todas las personas
que creen a priori que
no tienen nada que ver con esto
cuando cada día miran
a una persona desde el déficit
Y como me dijo una compañera mía:
en vez de mirarme
los lindos ojos que tengo,
me miran los bastones o las muletas.
Entonces, ocupa mucha parte
de mi tiempo pensar en esta conducta.
A veces todo el mundo cree que trabajo
directamente con personas con discapacidad.
Parte de mi trabajo
tiene que ver con eso,
pero en realidad mi preocupación está en
el universo de personas sin discapacidad.
Porque tengo un sueño,
tengo un sueño que es salir
a la calle todos los días
y encontrarme con los 2 millones
de personas con discapacidad
viviendo la vida libremente.
Ser libre implica elegir,
elegir dónde estar, elegir quién ser
cómo crecer, cómo desarrollarse,
cómo vivir...
Y les aseguro que ese nivel de libertad
está muy lejos de la realidad para las
personas que viven en este país hoy.
Cuando decimos discapacidad
en el imaginario, en cada
una de nuestras mentes
en nuestra cultura,
aparecen varias palabras:
feos, pobrecitos,
excluidos,
marginados, perdedores...
En verdad conozco muchas personas
con discapacidad felices
y descubrí y coincidiremos,
que la felicidad es una sensación
subjetiva, es una construcción única
lo que me hace feliz seguramente
no los hace felices a Uds..
Entonces eso me lleva a otra pregunta:
¿Por qué dictamos sentencia
sobre los otros?
¿Desde qué lugar,
desde qué poderosa mirada
cada día de nuestra vida
dictamos una sentencia
sobre una persona
que es diferente a mí?
Me preocupa el problema de la diferencia
porque no puedo creer realmente
que estemos en el tiempo que estamos
todavía comportándonos...
con comportamientos primitivos
¿Qué hacía el hombre frente
a aquello que no conocía?
Huía, y seguimos huyendo
solo que ahora somos
un poco más sofisticados
porque ignoramos, ese es el mejor
mecanismo de huida que tenemos hoy,
o atacamos
solo que ahora atacamos desde
la más cruda segregación.
Tenemos ese poder implícito
en nuestra mirada, en nuestras
acciones de cada día.
Me hago muchas preguntas
muchas tienen que ver con...
cómo se siente una persona que
no entra en el modelo de estética
que nos propone la sociedad
en la que vivimos;
cómo se construye un parámetro de éxito;
cuáles son las cosas que hacen
que uno pertenezca o no,
se sienta reconocido por el otro o no;
cómo eso incide en mi capacidad de estar.
Pienso mucho sobre esto
y no tengo muchas respuestas
pero me gustaría que
Uds. también lo piensen.
Trabajando en este tema,
observando conductas
y pensando sobre esto,
descubro que la cuestión
de la discapacidad
genera a priori dos percepciones:
una que tiene que ver con el temor,
el temor que me paraliza,
el temor que me aleja;
y la otra que tiene
que ver con la impotencia.
Me da impotencia, no sé qué hacer,
no tengo información
no sé qué hacer con la persona
que tengo adelante.
Y realmente quiero decirles que
ninguna de estas dos cuestiones
nos están facilitando lo más
maravilloso que nos puede ocurrir
cuando nos encontramos con
alguien diferente a nosotros,
que es reconocerlo,
descubrirlo, explorarlo...
Esa maravillosa singularidad
que nos hace únicos,
un "evento" realmente.
Parece ser que los humanos nos estamos
tomando demasiado tiempo les diría
para darnos cuenta
de lo importante que es
celebrar ese encuentro
y ese descubrimiento que
propone la relación con otro,
con otro que es distinto a mí.
Me gustaría pedirles que...
si podemos encender la luz,
que levanten la mano
las personas que tienen
una persona con discapacidad
en sus familias,
que se sientan libres de hacerlo.
Muchas gracias.
Así como Uds.,
en 1 de cada 5 hogares de nuestro país
vive hoy una persona con discapacidad.
Sin embargo, salimos
a la calle y no los vemos
Muchos de Uds. estarán en la universidad
y seguramente no tendrán
un compañero con discapacidad,
o un compañero en sus lugares de trabajo,
o un profesional que atienda
la salud de sus hijos, o que los eduque
¿Dónde están las personas
con discapacidad?
Todavía están en su casa,
todavía están esperando una oportunidad
o un entorno que facilite su permanencia
y su integración verdadera
para poder aportar toda la riqueza
que una persona con discapacidad puede
aportar en la construcción de este país.
No solo social, económica, cultural...
desde su propia singularidad
y desde su diversidad.
Tenemos un pendiente
enorme en este sentido
y el pendiente está en nuestras manos
No va a bajar una nave espacial
y nos va a convertir a todos
en personas abiertas,
interesadas en el otro.
Es un trabajo personal.
Yo soy obrera de la construcción,
en realidad en vez de trabajar con
ladrillos, trabajo con la palabra;
me dedico a construir "rampas culturales",
así me gusta llamar mi trabajo.
Realmente creo que tenemos una
oportunidad por delante maravillosa
y que no podemos desaprovecharla.
En siglo XXI, tantos avances,
tanta ciencia, tanto desarrollo
y estamos perdiendo el valor
de la humanidad misma.
Tengo poquito tiempo.
Solo quiero decirles que en esta
construcción necesitamos muchas manos
Esto no puede quedar en manos
de un ente celeste.
Algo tiene que ocurrir...
algo tiene que ocurrir para que todos
los niños puedan ir a la escuela,
a una escuela cualquiera,
no a la escuela especial.
Algo tiene que ocurrir para que todos
los jóvenes puedan ir al secundario
en igualdad de condiciones
y todas las personas puedan
encontrar un trabajo
y no tengamos los niveles de
desempleo que tenemos en Argentina
para personas con discapacidad
en edad económicamente activa.
Algo tiene que ocurrir, y ese
algo está en nuestras manos...
Entonces, quiero invitarlos
en un evento como este
un evento de encuentro,
de pensamiento y de celebración
quiero invitarlos a celebrar
la diversidad.
Que no es más ni menos que
celebrar la vida misma ¿verdad?
Para terminar,
quiero pedirles que me acompañen
y cierren los ojos.
Y no hagan trampas, porque
de acá los estoy viendo.
Cierren los ojos...
imaginen, les voy a describir algo.
Es morocha,
tiene ojos oscuros, muy brillantes;
es hija,
es hermana,
es esposa,
es mamá de dos hijos,
es una trabajadora, es una profesional,
es una ciudadana,
es una persona interesada
en construir la Argentina,
en poner su valor para
la construcción de este país.
Les voy a presentar a Laura,
una mujer con futuro.
Ella es Laura.
Y simplemente quiero convocarlos
a todos para que a partir de hoy
se comprometan, junto con nosotros,
a celebrar esta nueva forma
de estar en este mundo
y a hacer desde cada lugar
en el que están
un país mejor para todos, "con" todos
aplicando todos sus talentos
al servicio de la inclusión.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)